السودان بعد اكثر من 20 يوما من الحرب
المفتوحه على الاسوا البلد يتمزق سياسيا
وامنيا واجتماعيا وشعبه يعيش كارثه
انسانيا كبرى نادرا متوثقها الكاميرات
العنف بلغ مستوى من الخطوره جعل الاجانب
يغادرون والسفارات تغلق ابوابها ومؤسسات
الامم المتحده تعمل عن بعد من دول الجوار
ومنسق المنظمه لحالات الطوارئ مارتن
جريفيث ينتظر منذ ايام موعدا مع قاده
المعسكرين المتصارعين يبدو ان انتظاره
لضمانات من اجل ممر امن للمساعدات
الانسانيه سيطول كثيرا لهدن تحترمت ولا
تحذير وصل صداه الى من بيتهم السلاح محنه
المدنيين السودانيين تكبر وتتعاظم مع كل
دقيقه وليس ساعه تغتال فيها فرص عوده
الامان المفقود تفاصيل انهيار القطاع
الصحي
ومخيفه يستغيث مسؤول مستشفى احمد قاسم في
الخرطوم بحري بقرب نفاذ المواد الطبيه
الخاصه بمرضى غسيل الكلاب من جهتها حدثت
لجنه اطباء السودان قائمه المرافق
المتضرره من دوامه العنف سبعه عشر مستشفى
تضررت جراء القتال اخلي عشرون قصرا منذ
الخامس عشر من ابريل الماضي 60 مستشفى من
اصل 88 في الخرطوم خارج الخدمه الان وتلك
العامله لتقدم كامله خدماتها تحذير اخر من
اليونيسف عن طفوله تغتال في السودان
بالرصاص وبتداعيات حرب اخفقت الامم
المتحده في منع اندلاعها
المنظمه تلقى التقارير تفيد بان 190 طفلا
قتلوا 1700 اخرين اصيبوا بجروح خلال 11
يوما الاولى فقط من القتال الذي بدا في
الخامس عشر من ابريل الواقع سيء من جميع
النواحي بدون صيغه الاح
انه اذا تواصل الامر على هذه الحل سيكون
هناك اكثر من 860 الف لاجئ من السودان الى
دول الجوار من الصعب يحصلوا اعداد
النازحين داخل البلاد ولكنهم ايضا بعشرات
الالاف ويعتمدون على التعاضد الاجتماعي
لمواجهه المحنه واوزار صراع الاخرين على
السلطه من وما الذي اوصل السودان الى كل
هذه الالم المتحاربون ام الداعمون لهم ام
المجتمع الدولي العاجز عن فعل اي شيء ما
عدا الشعور بالقلق مما يجري هناك